[Music]
are you ready for a new start
are you sick and tired of earth and all
its problems
well here's your chance to start fresh
by moving
to titan yeah you heard me titan
saturn's largest moon could be your new
home away from home
how would we power our new home
what would we eat and
how would we handle crime
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we colonized titan
even if you weren't one and a half
billion kilometers away from earth
starting a community is extremely hard
luckily for you we're here to help you
work out the kinks
[Music]
you know the first thing they teach you
in real estate is location
location location and thankfully
titan fits the bill titan is the most
earth-like place in our solar system
because of its thick atmosphere
and water on its surface of course there
are some differences you're going to
have to get used to
differences like titan having 1.6 times
the atmospheric pressure of earth
that's the same pressure you'd feel
diving about 5 meters down into the
ocean
on the plus side titan has seasonal
changes that would let you rock your new
fall getup
and i hope you like it because on titan
a season
lasts about seven earth years
the main pull however is titan's
abundant supply of hydrocarbons
they could be used to build shelters and
for energy sources
okay that was a good enough reason for
us to set up shop here but
how exactly would we create our
community
well the first step would be to send a
fleet of smart robots
to start prepping for human settlers
the robots could start constructing
houses
buildings and mines since
titan is filled with hydrocarbons such
as methane and
ethane it makes sense to convert them
into plastic and use them as building
materials
as for powering the settlement we'd have
to cover about
10 percent of titan's surface with solar
panels
that's no small feat but with a little
elbow grease and
scientific know-how we could pull it off
next it's time to make ourselves at home
but what would life on titan be like
anyway
well first you're going to have to
bundle up the surface temperature on
titan
is minus 179 degrees
translation it's really cold
we would need to build large domes with
self-sustaining ecosystems for us to
stay alive
those self-sustaining ecosystems would
provide us with food
we would take the lessons learned from
the international space station on
how to grow lettuce peas and radishes
these have all been successfully grown
in their space garden and
will help us to understand how low
gravity affects plants
with less sunlight reaching titan than
our plants are used to
we'd need to add additional lighting to
make our galactic greenhouse thrive
[Music]
but what if vegetables weren't cutting
it what if you had a craving
for a juicy meaty earth burger
well we could use cellular agriculture
to grow meat from animal cells in large
bioreactors and for snacks
we could farm insects
okay hear me out insects are a great
source of protein
and farming insects is energy efficient
as it doesn't require a lot of farmland
energy or water come on just try some
[Music]
so we could set up our colony and work
together in harmony to
hey who stole my cricket sandwich
like in any society not everyone is
going to play
nice so what do we do about
crime in space thankfully
we have a contingency plan a researcher
at the university of california
suggested that committing a crime on
mars would be
so hard to do that no one would be
tempted to try it
the same could be said for our titan
colony
this is because of all the monitoring
data that would be needed such as
airlocks opening and closing exact gps
data about your whereabouts
your vital signs adrenaline levels and
so on
if someone did commit a crime all that
data would make it
pretty easy to identify the criminal
that'll teach you this is my cricket
sandwich
[Music]
and you don't have to be a rocket
scientist to go to titan
in the beginning we would need skilled
laborers to build it
with engineers nurses farmers and cooks
much like the way a community on earth
is made up of
all kinds of people with different
skills we would need someone like you
in our new home on titan
but what if the trip to titan didn't
go so well and you ran into some
issues how could you survive a rocket
explosion
well you can find out in our new show
how to survive